[Music]
welcome to view from the top
we're excited to have beth ford the
president and ceo of wendell lakes join
us today
beth's 35-year career spans six
industries at
seven companies since joining wanda
lakes in 2011
she's held a variety of roles leading
the farmer to fork business offerings
today she's a passionate advocate on
behalf of farmers in rural america with
the goal of connecting people
particularly in urban areas to the
farmers and rural communities who grow
their food
a native of sioux city iowa beth holds a
bachelor's degree from iowa state
university and an mba
from columbia university she sits on the
board of directors for the business
roundtable
the fortune 150 company pacar and
numerous other industry
non-profit and university boards beth
has been recognized by fortune magazine
as one of the world's 50 great leaders
and most powerful women
and was named to fast companies most
productive people
and best leaders list among other honors
we're really looking forward
to hearing more about beth's story in
today's conversation with adrian negros
nba21 thank you beth thank you so much
for
joining us today at the gsb by zoom and
we're really excited to hear
what you have to say beth it is so great
to have you with
us today well it's so terrific to be
here as i said i wish i could be
there but i'm happy to be with you all
this will work um as we chatted a second
ago
i grew up in indiana and i was living in
minneapolis before coming to school
it's not often that we get a leader from
the midwest talking to my classmates
the campus is just thrilled again so
thank you
i'm happy to be here and what do you
mean you don't get a lot of people from
the midwest
this is where it's all happening people
this is where it's happening
we'll convince them very shortly okay
i'm sure of it
there's a number of things i want to
talk about beth including your
experience growing up in iowa
leading a fortune 200 and some broader
topics like the food supply chain and
rural broadband access
but let's start by going back to sioux
city iowa
it's your home it's where you grew up
it's a town of about 80 000 people and
you have a large family there's eight
brothers and sisters including yourself
you've had a room which you shared with
your three sisters and got one drawer
all to yourself
what was it like growing up in your
household well as i said you know you
had to have a drawer because you needed
the place to put the handy down
you know so there it is um you know i
was number five of eight i had two older
brothers two older sisters
a younger sister two younger brothers um
and my dad was a truck driver we were
very much a working class family
um but no different than any other
working class families
there um education was important to my
parents
um my mom who is still with us my father
has passed
uh my mother was i think has been the
most significant role model to me in my
life
an incredibly resilient woman left in an
orphanage when she was five by her
parents with her brothers
with her brother and then um was adopted
eventually at age
ten and here's a woman who became a
nurse
and then became a minister at the end in
between she was a psychologist a
therapist she would say she worked on
their
their body their minds and their spirits
and so she's
she's been an incredible role model and
so during that time what's it like
growing up in a family of eight kids
when you're working class
and you're kind of in a room with your
three siblings
it's noisy um dinner is
a you know killer bee killed exercise
you know ate a lot of chicken necks and
wings that since i didn't know there was
white meat on a chicken until i was at
least 17.
and my older brothers were out of the
house um you know it was
it was very much a um a moving kind of a
target
in our um in our family uh
my siblings have achieved um you know
good professional careers that went to
college um but you had to kind of work
your way
to college so to your your point you
know the first jobs
i had were de-tasseling corn it was a
babysitter now i'm going to tell you i
still i haven't told you adrian i've
saved this for you
so i was probably 12 or 13 i was
babysitting because you know you make
some money i was making like two dollars
an hour i got like five kids
the oldest of the kids was probably
about my age
he grabbed the keys to the car that they
had
and he floored this thing and he went
through the house
i never got any babysitting jobs after
that shocker
you know i was like oh my gosh i had to
call my mom i was like oh mom
this is not good um but i did all of
those kinds of jobs the
the detasling corn i worked as a night
cashier
i cleaned toilets in college i
i mean i had all sorts of jobs and it
was very much a working class
uh family that the expectation it was if
you wanted to achieve something you had
to invest in your education
and yourself and as well you had to work
hard to get what you wanted
makes a lot of sense to me beth and you
mentioned of course the two dollars i
want to make sure the audience and us
are on the same page
because adjusted for inflation this is a
rough estimate because i passed my
finance class i didn't crush it
but it's something like 10 or 11 in
today's terms so it's like
not too shabby but it was hard work
you're up at 5am right
up at five got onto a bus with my
siblings um
you put in long long pants and
um you know long sleeves so that you can
get eaten up on details on corn
um and it was hot and it was you know it
was
it wasn't appealing work perhaps that
was there was a little strategy there
like you need to work harder on your
brain
so that you aren't having to do this for
a living going forward
but you know it again it taught me so
many lessons
in my life all of those jobs that were
not glamorous
that involved manual labor wasn't just
the i didn't want to do this it was the
value of hard work it was the value of
these people
um every day and so i i'm grateful for
that
and in fact i almost feel concerned
that my i have three children and of
course they've never had to
deal with any of those kinds of
challenges where you have the wrong
clothes or you know you don't get to go
somewhere because you can't afford it
they don't ever have to deal with that
and i kind of think that they're missing
out
i imagine that these experiences though
help you connect with your farmers in a
very personal way you can
relate to working hard being out in the
corn fields so i think there's a
positive there and i'm sure
your kids learn through the stories that
you and your partner jill share with
them
i think so i mean jill my my wife uh
we've been together around 28 years and
she's a peoria
illinois native she her family came from
farming as well
and um uh you know our came from the
midwest
and and we're in farming and she was uh
one of the first class of women at west
point
and then we met at columbia her at the
law school minor the business school
um so you hope that they they take away
this value of hard work which both of us
obviously
um have have had a central to our lives
but you know it's hard i think sometimes
it's harder for me just to say no
because i can remember what it's like to
not have something
but i need to do better make sure i tell
them no make it hard for them
i would say hard work wasn't the only
lesson you got growing up you got what
you called and you mentioned your mom
carol and you got what you called the
most important leadership advice
ever from her when you were young so
could you take us back to that
conversation or a moment
what did she say that stuck so closely
are you talking about don't be afraid to
want you
to ask for what you want that's exactly
what it was was i was probably 12 or 13
i was having a tantrum about something
i don't even remember what it was but i
you know i'm tall my mother is a
smaller woman she's probably five two or
five three and i'm six feet tall
obviously take after my father who was a
big very big man
and he and i'm you know i'm having that
tantrum
i can't believe you didn't do this and
she said um
she said do you think i'm a mind reader
i am not a mind reader if you want
something you ask for it
and for whatever reason i can see her
face i thought that that made such good
logical sense to me she you know it
stopped me cold
and through my life i've i've reflected
back on that
where there are times i think in your
professional career and those of you
who've already had the career now you're
back at
mba school and and you'll go back out um
i think sometimes we're reluctant or we
think
gosh i'm a great performer they're going
to just notice me
that just doesn't really happen um it
really doesn't and you can't be you know
you don't want to be a braggart or you
know you want to have humility but you
can't be shy
to make clear to your supervisors your
leaders remember what your aspiration is
what your ambition is to
to achieve otherwise people aren't going
to just guess
nobody i promise you cares more about
your career than you do
nobody and um you have to remind
yourself of that
and do do what you need to do to
position yourself
to me that means you enable others
success
you don't want to be the guy or the gal
that nobody wants to work with because
they're you're all about yourself
um and instead you should enable their
success
um and and then you'd be surprised that
kind of it's a virtuous circle
everybody wants to to be part have you
part of the team
when you when you care legitimately
about somebody else
i think it makes a ton of sense you know
thinking about me
and our audience listening i think we
all go in with like we need to be humble
respectful and that's all true but that
doesn't mean you can't be
confident yourself and a self-advocate
and say hey i deserve this
i work hard i drive results and i think
that's just an incredible message that
your mom gave you and i'm glad you
shared it with all of us
yeah i don't i don't even say i deserve
it what i what i generally say is
um this is something i aspire to what do
i need to do
do you see me in that role first of all
and sometimes people will tell you no
they don't they don't see you as
achieving something and to me that's a
gift
it is a gift but you have to get
yourself the my right mindset to hear
that
it's a gift because then you can ask why
why isn't it what do i need to do
and if it's not they don't ever see you
that way that that's not your right
place
you know and that's a gift to me that's
not a oh it feels bad even if it might
feel bad
for a moment um you have to say boy what
a gift
i'm so glad and grateful i learned that
so i usually just say you know this is
what i aspire to is this possible do you
see me in that way what do i need to do
to position
myself what are the other investments i
need to make what do i need to learn
um to be put in that position i love
that i think it's something we can all
use
moving forward in our professional
careers beth i want to ask about
post college so after iowa state so
that's go cyclones right you're not a
hawkeye fan i assume no i'm not a
hawkeye i'm a cyclone
got it um after iowa state you go to oil
and gas you mentioned your dad worked
on the truck so i think similar
industries
you were on the tanker right you
described it as you and the dudes
on the night shift well i
you know so out of undergrad i got this
job interview no
you need to understand okay again i'm
kind of a working-class kid so
i had like one suit one dress this is
back in the day you know so i was like
wearing a blue
button-down thing and i had like this
gray suit and i got this
this job interview with mobile oil and i
went to their headquarters in virginia
and i remember this so vividly because
we were staying at
a hotel and the doors were on the inside
you know
this was a motel no this was real stuff
there was real food there so i was like
okay this is fancy
so i go to the interview and
i really liked the company and so they
said okay great you're going to los
angeles you're going to um you're going
to go through operations training so my
background in
a lot of my career i was in line
operations yes i managed tanker barge
trucks
trucking facilities i was in the
refineries there was a manufacturing
facilities i did some time on the
trading floor
um i you know so i had probably nine
different jobs
in nine years with them um so this the
me and the dudes yeah it was constantly
me
and you know 50 men or a hundred men or
you know me in training in south padre
with 50 guys or 20 guys
and that story i tell that you may be
referring to is when you're
running a terminal for an oil industry
or
a trucking facility you have to go
through you have to go to reno to learn
how to put out a fire
and then you're in south padre to learn
about what do you do if there's an oil
spill so i was down in south padre and
it was me and
you know 25 guys and um part of the
training is you're going up in a
helicopter you got a chart
where this might be so i'm i'm there at
the the
place we're going to depart and the guy
yells out he's like having y'all out
your name
and i need you to tell me what you're
waiting so i was like what
this is off the hook i'm not doing that
we're not we're not
i went over i said what are you talking
about he said oh we need to make sure we
balance the
aircraft i said i'm going to write this
down on a piece of paper i'm going to
give it to you this is between you and
me
so i'm standing there and he puts it in
the computer and
it's five pounds everywhere i said
that's five pounds heavy because every
woman lies about their weight
you know it's great those are great fun
jobs i mean i had to call
i had to tell one of the guys that
worked with me on the dock to bring his
teeth to work
he kept showing up without his teeth
that's like tommy it's super distracting
man you've got to bring your teeth in
okay
you're killing me with that i mean those
jobs though
um it's wonderful and i never was
uncomfortable there and the reason i
think is because i kept thinking this
could be my father
my uncle my my cousins um
this was not abnormal for me
and i felt pretty clearly based on what
i saw from my father when he would come
home from work
or from come off the road you know the
most important thing i needed to do was
show up every day
in a consistent positive
forward-looking manner as a supervisor
or as a
manager and help them understand how
much their work was valued
you know it's you what is your job today
your job is to put out this many on the
line or
you have to make this many stops and
there's real value to that work
and unfortunately i think we minimize it
now today of course during the pandemic
everybody who's a driver or who's
doing that kind of work and food
production for instance are highly
valued
because we see that um but i learned
that lesson pretty clearly that
i needed to make sure they understood i
respected them um i respected the hard
work they did every day and
um and i think that that was a real
benefit for me
that's incredible beth and i think kind
of looking back on what you've spoken
about
just great values you know being a
self-advocate hard work and
determination
what you just mentioned being a good
team player even when your teammates ask
you what your weight is
still be an advocate for them um you
know to me it's no surprise you've had
such incredible professional success
seven companies six industries ending
atlanta lakes
i want to talk a little bit about your
first couple roles there so
chris polisinski the former ceo had lots
of faith in you
within a few years being in arden hills
minnesota you led multiple p
l's that drove the business so how are
you able to drive
such high confidence from chris and you
being there so quickly
yeah um well i'm going to talk about
that but i also want to talk about one
other thing that i think is important
for the wide land of lakes and thus why
i think i
also was able to accelerate my career
there um
in the interim between mobile and then
atlanta lakes in those other industries
i one of them was in publishing i was in
publishing scholastic
you know clifford the big red dog harry
potter and his
little brown books um the twilight
series and what i learned about myself
in those jobs
was why would i do that well because um
the job
at landlady all right uh scholastic was
about literacy in children
and so there was a power of meaningful
work
to me i enjoyed for instance
being on the trading floor for mobile
oil but i didn't love it
intellectually i understood it it was
fun
but it didn't speak to my soul the way
the mess as i say the mess of the human
condition speaks to me
and this opportunity to deal with
something like literacy and children
atlanta lakes when i went there i had
first thought i'm not going to do that
i was living in new york city jill was
running a hedge fund
i was traveling around the world we had
our three children i'm like oh you know
we're pretty good here
in new york city and then you know
something about the structure
of the company about um
feeding a growing world population about
farmers that spoke to me
when i started so to your point i
started as chief supply chain officer
and i was running all the operating
functions and it's a pretty big platform
it's about 300
you know plus manufacturing et cetera
facilities chemicals
food processing you name it um and then
i picked up
uh r d and then i picked up i t
and then i started running the
businesses and then i picked up the last
business and i became ceo
um during that time i go back to being
an advocate for yourself
i did meet with chris quite a bit um i
of course
got a lot of visibility to the board and
i talked to the chief human race
resource officer and i was pretty clear
with chris that my ambition my
aspiration
was to take over as ceo of this company
now i had been in position in two other
companies
to be considered for ceo and i made the
definitive decision
that was not my right place that i
could do it but i there were others
that were actually going to be better
than me i thought in like in publishing
i think if you're in publishing you
love that you know all the editors the
publisher i mean you just know it
and i thought it was interesting but it
didn't speak to my soul so
atlanta lakes what i think that they
saw was my in my conversation with him
was an about the ability to continue to
stretch me
active dialogue with him and then of
course you always in those situations
have to deliver results otherwise
you know you're not going to be you're
not going to be given that next um
next step in your career absolutely and
you of course drove incredible results
throughout your career atlanta lakes
last friday super amazing q3 earnings so
congratulations from us
i want to ask about the structure i
think you mentioned it briefly the co-op
structure
it's not super familiar to everyone on
the west coast the silicon valley types
so could you tell us about what that
means for you as ceo
yeah the cooperative so i've worked in a
small private i've worked in private
period i've worked in
large corporations public trade
companies i'm on public hub boards
in a cooperative structure the members
or the owners
own you okay so i report to a board
right now that has 28 board members
um they are elected locally
so there are maybe five out of
california for instance in the central
valley which is one of the most
productive food
production areas in the world um
and from that they it's almost like
think of it as like the house of
representatives
but i i say to them when they're elected
once you step into the boardroom it's
governance it's you're not the house of
representatives you're not there to
worry about whether joey
had some animal husbandry issue okay
your
a board member of a fortune 200 company
and that's a big responsibility
um the structure then we hold back when
from our earnings um and that earnings
the earnings are generated from
either milk for instance we have dairy
producers
most people know lando lakes for our
dairy production we also own purina
animal nutrition we own them build
technologies which works with growers
on the aquarium trutera sustainable um
production business and then we also
have an ngo
venture 37 which does work around the
world with the gates foundation and
others on smallholder farmers etcetera
so this structure is interesting because
really
we collateralize based on the assets and
based on the holdback
from these members we do have a
preferred tranche so it acts like equity
on our balance sheet
but i'm not out in the market selling
shares right so you really
have to you know it's a skinny margin
business
in food production because you have some
part this commodity some part that is
differentiated or value-added or
cpg-like
but you have to you really that margin
is so critical because
it's reinvested in the business um and
then there's hold back from the members
for our for what we earn some of it goes
back almost like a dividend
we call it patronage back to them some
of it is held back at the corporate
level
so you know there's been great growth
because let's think about it debt
financing right now i mean money is
pretty cheap
um and we've got this private equity
trunk so we haven't been held back
in our aspiration for growing these
businesses
but we also don't access um
you know capital markets in terms of of
um
putting out in different shares we do
report we go through the whole sox
compliance that everybody would be
familiar with
we i meet with the rating agencies i
meet with investors
kind of a similar situation so it is
different this company was started in
1921 by upper midwest dairy farmers
trying to get power in the channel and
get their sweet cream butter into the
population
centers in the east so they formed a
marketing cooperative
that was successful so additionally they
formed a supply cooperative
the supply cooperative would be the
animal feed side or your goods or
the other things so it's a fully
integrated platform literally we go
right from the farm
we have to take our members milk i can't
say no we don't want it
because there's too much of it no that's
our job is to find a home for it
um and you know the cows are milking two
or three times a day so you've got to
figure that out
um all the way to retail
right beth you mentioned your board and
back in july 2018 they named you a ceo
reading the news release i love it they
focus on metrics
you drove great performance in your
multiple roles let's put the people that
do the best work in the highest
positions but more personally to you
and i'm sure this decision is made over
a number of weeks but can you take us
back to the email
or the phone call the moment it became
really real to you
i'm about to lead a fortune 200 company
what were you feeling
well we had been talking about this
for a couple of years obviously and then
really these processes start
early if you're in a company and you're
in
um the top level if you're in the
c-suite or even before that
generally like as soon as i took over a
ceo i started to look at who's could
take my job
in the future so it's really fairly
early because you're working on
developing them
um what i did is and what they did is
not on
um dissimilar to other companies in
which i'm sitting on the board on their
comp committee or elsewhere you go
through a whole
process i did business cases think of it
just like
mba school i did interviews the exec
committee which were
there were eight gentlemen who were on
that committee ran the process
there were other internal candidates
there was another gentleman candidate
and
and then they made a decision up front
that they weren't going to be external
now most companies
will say if the performance of the
business is what is expected
has been expected will stay inside if
you want disruption
um you want to go outside that's kind of
a general
rule of thumb i've made it pretty clear
and i think most people in my position
would if i've been there
seven you know six or seven years at
that point i'm cool i've run everything
i'm running everything
and you go outside that's a vote of no
confidence right
and i said that if you do that that will
be a vote of no confidence and i will
not stay
and they said no we're going to go
inside there are a couple of other
candidates so you go through a whole
process
they bring in an external firm to
interview you as well
you've got interviews multiple times
with this exec committee
they're doing background checks they're
checking any board i've sat on
they're doing you know they're looking
at my if do i have any legal
issues so it's a multi-week
process actually multiple months and
towards the end what they did is they uh
called and said we want you to fly into
denver
where the whole board will be and during
that
time um i met with the entire board 28
of them
i stood up and i gave them my strategic
vision for the company
um and then i stood up there for
probably three hours
and they could ask me any question and i
would answer those
and then i left the room and when i left
they voted
and they made me ceo and i came back in
so um
then you know i said congratulations
then i went down the hall and started
doing press they had already set up
um you know i think kim is on the phone
uh my
head of communications had already set
up interviews with wall street journal
and with
um some of the local uh publications
here
and then it was very funny because my
assistant said well
you know do you want us to put a plane
over there and i was like well i'm at
the airport i'll just go and then
you're kind of by yourself so now you've
done the interview you're kind of
hanging out
my you know jill my spouse was traveling
with her mother
to the west coast all my kids were at
camp so it's like just me
and so i guess i went to the bar at the
airport and had a beer
and then i got home and it was just me
and the cat for god's sake i'm like
this is kind of an anticlimactic moment
actually
you know who's checking out the outfit
for tomorrow when they make this
announcement i guess you are
madge the cat because even the dog's
gone
i wanted to ask i wanted to ask where do
you celebrate in the twin cities after
being named ceo apparently you celebrate
madge is what i just apparently it's
like yeah i guess i get to have one good
glass of wine
um and you know now he's home now you
know it's it's very funny of course
i called my family um i called you know
my
my siblings and my mom and um
they they were aware and um and it was
joyous and
and then eventually my family came home
but the first few days of course
that wasn't the case and it was probably
fine because there's so much that
happens
on that first day when you step back
into headquarters
and you tell everybody okay um that you
know
it was me who was selected as ceo and we
talked about what's next and
do constant rounds of interviews or
talking to customers
or talking to shareholders i want to
talk about a couple broader topics beth
that you work very hard and
your team also first on real broadband
access
so i think simply put tens of millions
of americans are online
and we sit here and it's wonderful we
can chat via zoom
but there are kids right now that they
just don't have any form of education
and i know you've partnered with the
public and private sector
to address this what do we all need to
do better
so private public people listening right
now to this
to help students get online well the
first thing you need to do is be aware
that there is this gap that there are 18
to 20 million americans that lack
broadband access many of them lack
any access to you know cellular at all
and a majority of them are in rural
communities now they're also in
underserved areas so
i'm i'm working two things one i'm part
of the business run people i'm on their
board of directors i'm right now on
a committee with jamie dimon and robert
smith
around you know a wealth creation
especially for underserved communities
for for the black african-american
communities
so that's a portion and there's a like a
third
over a third of african-american black
households lack access to broadband
in rural communities it's equally
startling and i think people don't
understand
they think it's somebody else's problem
i keep saying listen
this is an american problem the fact of
the matter is
that um food security is a national
security issue
look at the presidency in uh our chimney
in china what is he saying food security
is a major issue for them
um i could talk with you at length and
probably
your eyes will place over about what we
have going on over there but um
uh but it is a national security issue
so it's not somebody else's problem it
leaves us less secure
as a nation the second thing is yes the
kids there
95 of farms are still family owned and
so they have families these are
you know young children and at the same
time they're having to make a decision
do i run some of the equipment
with whatever bandwidth i have or do the
kids go to school
teachers are having to drive out to
these farms and get paper homework
the families then drive an hour to next
to sit next to a school bus where
they've got hot spots
so they can get enough bandwidth to
finish their homework on their cell
phone
it's just not acceptable there's a
shortage of forty thousand doctors in
rural communities
there's uh you know over a third of
children
are growing up in growing up food
insecure there's a surge of housing
so there are so many issues here what i
say
you say what can we do the first thing
you need to do is be aware
that this is really a major issue we can
talk all we want
you're in the valley and i go so many
times in there and i talk to
entrepreneurs
and they've got the greatest tech and i
say none of it can be used
in these communities unless we get some
technology in there some broad but basic
wiring
this should be a right like electricity
like mail delivery and um
and otherwise all of this innovation
which these
this technology that is now under
development
um can help us solve climate climate
change
we just started a partnership with nori
which wants to be the ebay of carbon
credit trading
we're doing something else in in iowa
right now where
we're connecting um on water quality
these farms and we're giving the score
with our trutera inside engine it's got
over a trillion data points
where they can help improve their
decision making on the farm
which will improve water quality and
seepage into this
into this um water these these rivers
and from that they get a certain amount
per acre
we've got to think of other incentive
structures for these farmers
we can't have what it is this year 40
billion dollars of subsidies from the
government
farmers don't want to be on the dole
they want
you know open access to markets and we
have to think about what will likely be
this transition
leveraging technology that will
accelerate
in the ag sector for many many other
pressure points that we
you know again i don't want to have
everybody's eyes blaze over about why
electrification of the transportation
sector is going to have a deleterious
impact on the farm community
i could go into multiple issues that if
you really looked at it you'd say
wow wait a minute we got to pay
attention to this this is going to be
transformational moment in
our society right now
i have concern i'm sure all of you are
looking at this
looking at the concentration of covalent
cases in the upper midwest where i am
and where many of our members are and we
saw this
in february we started what's called our
american connection project
it's got over 125 different companies
now
we are partnered very directly with
microsoft i spent some time with satya
we announced a
a partnership a on tools development b
but be on also
closing this um this digital divide
um and one of the things that we saw was
that
since there's a shortage of doctors
what's going to happen when this goes
into the dakotas where it is right now
and um and so what we did was we
uh i i called all the governors and
sent out letters to the governors to the
speaker majority leader all of them to
say you need to change
your regulatory framework to allow for
prescriptions to be written
if you know if we see you on a zoom you
don't have to be in person
and to allow reimbursement rates to be
supportive of
funding a doctor or hospital and with
that
there's been an acceleration in health
care of telemedicine
uh the mayo clinic who were also
partnered with the cleveland clinic and
others
tell us that there have been more
telemedicine appointments in one day
than all of last year
so it's a long answer when you say what
are you doing
and what can you do but any of you who
are
looking at your careers i can tell you
all of these things are different
vectors on this transformational moment
in our in our society and the
opportunity is to recognize how enabling
technology is and if we do not have it
in these communities
it leaves us less secure as a nation
that's why job creation has lagged in
those areas and we can go on and on
it's incredible beth and i think you
know i imagine you've enlightened a lot
of people
listening and also invigorate a lot of
people listening that we can do more
and it's a group effort here it's it's
so clear to me
how much you care about communities in
the rural midwest
farmers kids you often are the only one
like yourself in the room whether that's
on the tank or with the dudes whether
that's running a 14 billion dollar
business
that's more than airbnb and lyft
combined if anyone's tracking in the
audience
beth i know that the press loves their
headlines they like their clicks and
their views
they like to put us into boxes when i
researched for this
i couldn't find an article that didn't
have in bold triple underlined
first open the gay female ceo and
except actually your press release from
their own company right the board
focused on results so
there was one um but you've talked about
authenticity and identity
in a matter-of-fact way it's who you are
it's in your dna
you want your members your employees to
bring their full selves to work so you
want to do the same i think though by
doing that
by being you it means a lot to a lot of
different communities
and for those of us that are part of the
lgbtq plus community 10
of the stanford class is for women
working in
male dominated industries or for the
little kid in iowa
who can look at you and say i could be
the next fortune 200 ceo
you're making a major difference and i
just want to say thank you
well that's very kind of you i you know
i
again it's i i don't find my life that
interesting i guess
you know it's probably that whole thing
might when i talked to one of my sons
today who's like oh what are you doing i
said oh i'm going to talk with
these uh students at stanford and he's
oh that's great you know blah blah blah
he's thinking about college
and he's like why do they want to listen
to you you know
because in real life um and i'm like
there's a lot here honey
you know he just he just laughed but i
think but i appreciate you saying that
what i recognize is all of us look for
moments of help
of hope or for some this possibility
that this is possible i've told these
stories about people who've kind of i've
had
literally thousands and thousands of
people connect with me
to talk about the uh you know leading
your authentic life and thank you
because that's so um helpful
including parents of young children who
have come out as gay
um but but one of the ones that was most
touching to me
was i was at an event
in uh it was here in the midwest
somewhere
and i was waiting to go speak to this to
the speaker who was going to come off
the stage and
and there was a big man and a big
gentleman i'm
six feet tall so if i'm telling you the
man's big that's a big man
um and he's you know he's down there i
thought oh well
i'll go over introduce myself i said hi
i'm i'm bath uh ford he goes oh i know
who you are
and i was like okay great um
i'm thinking what does that mean and he
goes i just want to say and he
he stood there and he he's he's
he started to cry and his you know his
lip was moving and i went over to him
and i said it's okay
it's it's gonna be okay he said no it's
my son my son is gay
and i said i said he goes and i'm just
so proud of you
and i'm so grateful for your courage
and i just i just held him i said he's
so fortunate to have a father like you
because all of us just want to be i
guess valued seen
um you know that that to me was
with such a profound moment i can
literally see it i i can feel it i
you know i just told you and saying i
just you know i'm grateful that you took
the time to say that to me and he goes i
just
i you know it's it's so hard but i'm so
grateful that you
you've been so authentic about this it's
it's
really that pain and that's why i say
most of the time when
i'm contacted like that i feel that pain
the
pain of the journey it it's not really
about me at all
it's about the pain or the emotion that
hope
for their themselves or their children
that of course all of us understand i
understand i've got three children
i hope everybody values them and they
think they're good people
you know and so most of the time i don't
think it's me at all
so when you say that i'm grateful it's
not me it's a reflection of this moment
of in what level of concern
pain joy happiness pride
is present um and so it's i'm grateful
to be there
with those people at that moment to to
to tell them they'll be okay that it's
gonna be okay
that's incredibly touching and powerful
thank you so much beth i have one last
question before we turn to audience q
a it's something we'll ask all of our
speakers this year it's obviously been
an incredibly challenging year
what principles do you rely on as a
leader when facing these tough moments
um calm is contagious calm is contagious
i i kind of gave everybody a minnesota
and you'll know this
view uh you know in the snowstorm in the
car
you don't jerk the wheel you pump the
brake just don't drink the wheel for
god's sake we're going for the ditch
and then the priority is always your
people your people your people
people now i've said i felt like i was
pretty engaged with my team before but
not nearly now i'm really reflecting
back and saying maybe i really wasn't as
present
because there's an intimacy here you're
sitting here i'm doing this for my home
office
i've had multiple situations i've done
you know i'm doing live interviews with
washington post or something in my
where my sons is low crawling in here in
his underwear to get his technology out
of my office you know
you see people the whole person you
don't see beth
who's the ceo you see beth she has these
kids oh we're gonna have to go
we're going camping i'm not really a
camper but now we're doing that
um you know there's the dog there's the
cat i mean it's
there's almost this um this joy of this
moment this intimacy and there's been a
flattening
right there's not this hierarchy really
it's this flattening i do lunch with
beth breakfast bath i do all sorts of
things
and um and so the principal of the
people first
and i tell them and we have a hotline we
have thousands of calls
i say you know you're not going to hear
me say
aren't we just looking at that you have
a job
because i don't know i'm not living
their journey you know i don't know
what's going on in their home
i don't know what the pressures are i
don't know what's going on with their
their parents their children whatever um
you you know you can't sit there and say
well you should just be grateful
no it's hard it's emotional this is a
marathon
and um and so the principle of the
people first
and second and third is is what i live
with and then like say keep calm
all this contagious make don't jerk the
wheel
let's stay let's stay in the lane here
wonderful message to leave us all with
beth thank you so much um that'll
conclude the main part of the interview
i will invite ed and nba2 to ask our
first question right now he should be on
in a second
hey ed hey beth hi beth i'm ed uh second
year mba student at the gsb
um thanks so much for being with us here
today uh my question
is related to the black lives matter
movement and the call for racial equity
uh your headquarters is only 15 miles
north of where george floyd was killed
last may and i guess my question is how
did you manage your staff in the days
and weeks that followed them
listen that was a painful awful
time still this is a fraud environment
let's all agree and it's not just here
in the twin cities
it's elsewhere around the country um
you know it was painful to see somebody
basically murdered in front of us right
and um there are a couple things that i
would know
there there are 17 fortune 500s here in
the twin cities that are headquartered
here
and um it is an expectation kind of the
midwest
you are involved in multiple
organizations as a ceo or as a senior
leader
if you're on the c-suite you you know 85
percent of our
of our team volunteers so this is an
active involved community but the fact
of the matter is there are disparate
outcomes
from an educational perspective for
minorities in this community and let's
agree
education is a foundational issue for
wealth creation
for job opportunities for all sorts of
things but we're
like 49th out of 50. it's just it's
stunning
not because there's not investment or
well-meaning people but clearly we're
not listening so would you say what did
you do how did you handle this as a
leader well the first thing we need to
do
is step back listened to our team we had
listening sessions as did many of the
companies in town it was led by our erg
our black african-american arg they
shared
their fear for their own children things
that had happened to them
um it was really eye-opening and painful
frankly
they asked then um you know for more
transparency
about our you know about uh
progress that we're making on diversity
and what i was
quite honest with is listen we attract
good talent uh minority talent we don't
retain well
we're clearly not connected we need to
do better
um this is going to be a journey so the
first thing we did is listen
we did put in place some other trend we
tried to be more transparent and then
outside the community because what i
recognize is when we
when people leave it's one thing to say
you're safe here
you're engaged inside the four walls of
the company another thing to say you're
safe in your community
or you should feel engaged in your
community and welcome
and so we uh have been trying to work in
the in our community
and in the communities in which we do
business to
you know to again say we will make
investment we want to make sure that
there's opportunity we want to make sure
the policies are
are appropriate we'll work with
government officials all sorts of things
so
it's a both an internal and external
thing and then it's really
saying it's not oh we did that session
now we're done
no no this is going to be an ongoing
thing
here minnesota business partners has the
ceos of all of the major corporations in
town
and then i sit on the business
roundtable board of directors and the
ceos there of
over 200 of the largest corporations um
you know that once led by w walmart
is we're all working to say what are the
investments we need to make to make a
change
thank you beth thanks ed one more
question
beth that's from morgan who's an nba one
hey morgan i'm oregon cast in
at gsb my question is around the future
of the industry
um so how will the agriculture industry
evolve to meet greater demands for food
with
higher sustainability requirements and
how do you prepare existing companies to
meet this challenge
well it's like you're in my head morgan
and you probably said it more articulate
than that
um you know the the fundamental issue is
that we're going to go to 9.5 to 10
billion people by 2050.
you almost have to double food
production in that time
with less land less arable and less
water right
freshwater is always already a problem
where's most population growth going to
occur
africa india and some of those areas are
are water scarce anyway and their
technology let's say if our
yield for corn production for instance
on average is 176 bushels an acre
they might get like you know 40 or less
so you know when you say what are we
going to do now and then let's think
about the transformation i get this a
lot
i met an event and somebody say what do
you think about plant-based path
that's what do you think about uh cell
base what do you think about and i'm
like yes i am an
advocate for innovation i'm gonna go
have a regular burger you have your
plant-based
okay i have a bird um but i don't need
to be
too equip about that because your
comment is really one that i spend a lot
of time with my team on
i mentioned this these other pressures
the electrification of
the transportation sector let me just
say
40 of corn produced goes into ethanol
biofuels now california you know
governor newsom i've met with him
personally i mean he's a thought leader
what did he say by 2035
all have to be you know electric
vehicles right
so biofuels which have been central to
the profitability
of farmers in addition to exports
we're next net exporter um
same thing for dairy producers what
happens
when biofuels are no longer necessary
how quickly is that going to happen of
course we could get into a lot of those
discussions what's going to happen with
the geopolitical environment then
when that transitions out of the middle
east i mean there are so many factors
here so
um when you say how do i think about it
or what are we doing
what i have to do is what i did
initially with
the um with the covet crisis
is i said i've got to protect the
enterprise i
immediately checked liquidity i had my
cfo running all sorts of models i talked
with our bankers i
mean i was looking at every scenario
okay can we withstand how long can we
stand what does this imply so i'm when
i'm thinking of this i have to protect
the enterprise and i have to protect the
members
these are families they have their
entire life's investment in this
if the sector is going to transition in
in different ways that we just discussed
whether it's biofuels whether it's
different types of food production
and let's all agree i'm a big believer
in biodiversity for instance we
basically have three main crops
that feed us and they're what thirty
thousand plant varieties or something i
mean we need to do something and
there's been a significant destruction
of biodiversity on the planet
so we know we have to do something and
what i have to do is think about it from
what is the member what are the what is
the
enterprise and then how do we set up
different incentive structures
to allow different revenue sources for
farmers
as this transition occurs or as we work
towards this
this because the technology is there to
feed this world's population i can tell
you that already
how do we know that there's excess
supply yet
we also have a billion people that go to
bed hungry every night
there's a distribution in economics and
an equity issue
and with that then there are multiple
ways i can answer your question morgan
what i think it takes is fundamentally
in the capitalist
society here is to come up with
different incentive structures
whether it's in carbon capture whether
it's in
you know as i said carbon credits there
are other ways that
incentives can be put together for
farmers
um and in this sector that will
stabilize them and allow us to move to
this transition
but is also better for society and for
other bigger problems like climate
change
thank you thank you so much to ed and
morgan for those awesome questions i've
got great classmates on my path i'm very
lucky to be
yes you are they're smart wanna end with
our lightning round beth it's a
tradition here on view from the top
i know you have experience so the
expectations are fine
i'm gonna do my best too okay i'm gonna
have you finish some sentences
from the perspective of a few different
people okay the first one's simple you
are yourself
i think you can do that all right so i'm
beth ford
over the past few months i've been binge
watching
uh yellowstone okay i thought maybe
that'd be a problem like i don't know
what i've been watching
i like it no no no i was thinking
yellowstone but then most recently i was
going back to something i watched a few
years ago newsroom
with jeff daniels i like that one so
most recently i've been watching that
and then i really want to get into this
what is it the queen's gambit
oh we just finished that amazing is it
good love it okay
gotta do that okay i'm a columbia mba
and i love that heart nyc go lions but
if i could have gone to any other
business school
it would be well of course stanford
but i'm not sure they would have taken
me so you know if you say what is the
presumption
the presumption is that they would have
wanted me right
i think i'll tell you i'll be very
honest and transparent why i went to
columbia
um i had met jill and
she was going to columbia law school and
i was actually going to go
further south for my mba and she told me
she thought it was a good idea if i went
to columbia
and i was kind of smitten so i said of
course i'm going to go to columbia
and there it is 28 years later great
okay i'm a stanford mba
and i hope one day to be as incredible a
power couple as
beth and jill to do that number one
thing i must do
is marry the right person
that that was i was thinking too you got
to find somebody first there's a lot of
singles in our class so
well i mean you if there is that is the
most important career decision you make
i'm not that's no lie
and we in my career and her i mean she
was a lawyer she was she was a
she went to west point and then she was
coming out she went to law school she
would scout and then she became went
into banking
and then she became the ceo of a hedge
fund and um
but we make life decisions about careers
right life decisions because it's never
individual you're hiring the whole
person we have three children
um we've got a very busy life so uh it's
who you marry that
is critical for your career i love that
makes sense
last one beth so i'm the ceo of landa
lakes
and i try to eat dinner as often as
possible with jill and my three kids
my favorite kid is
you know only if you want to but no
you know we asked my mother that one
time we said you know you have a favor
we know who it is because there's eight
of us and she goes no i don't but then
we gave her like half a glass of wine
which
is her max and she told us and we knew
it was my older brother michael
now michael we're like of course he's
the best of us
he's the smartest he was a navy captain
you know he's got like he's got his phd
and like something smart nuclear
engineering or something is teaching at
harvard
and we're like of course you love mike
best we all love mike best he's so much
smarter than us he's a good guy
so uh you know but i will not say i have
a favorite
i love them all that's that's the
perfect answer thank you so much beth
for the time today
thank you for all you do for farmers for
rural america and the great state of
minnesota
well thank you and thanks for the
invitation to be with you i'm wishing
all of you the very best
um good luck on your journey please stay
in touch be happy to help any way i can
you